why we don't have to cut are they
throwing us out are the police here
those move on hi I'm al pacino and you
didn't notice having to talk about a few
of my films Marty Bergman was my manager
for a while when I was very young and he
was interested in producing films
tarragon he was a great producer
I made five films him and that was the
first of five movies and he read this
article this book Peter Maass book about
this corruption in the police department
and it was Frank I didn't know you
didn't know me you find what I'm looking
you fire without a warning without a
[ __ ] brain in your head I read the
treatment of it you know not the script
didn't have a script yet they had a
treatment and it was interesting but I
couldn't tell from a treatment it's
always the script but I'll tell you I
met Frank Serpico they introduced me to
him
when I met the person that I was
supposed to do I didn't want to play him
it was an odd thing not because he was
negative or positive but I just felt
that couldn't be him well I met Frank I
knew there was something I could paint
there there was something that would I
could sort of serve I just felt it he
had an earring long hair and
strange-looking but he had a look in his
eye that I thought there it is I got to
know him very well hang with him then
Waldo's solved and Norman Wexler of this
Waldo solvers know right now you know
Midnight Cowboy and so he was a great
writer
and so I I did it with him and and
sitting lament of course is my first
meeting was Sydney it was an interesting
meeting that was very interesting I grew
to love him naturally but the first
impression of him was he said a couple
of things that seemed a bit
they were bit off-putting about me so I
felt that all who is this guy thing is
something then I start seeing some of
his films I thought he's a great
director that's who he is and then we
went on to the Dog Day Afternoon later
so then Serpico was made and it was the
first film Marty and I did together and
it was a good thing to have done our own
laundry around here now you could be
brought up on charges for they always
thought so but the reality is they are
in trouble I don't care if I'm in
trouble I don't care who gets it anymore
including myself because if I have to go
to outside am I gonna go stay where am I
gonna go you just wait took a hit for me
I've been waiting for you here Frank
I think the script is first you all know
the truth
the text it's very hard to you know he's
gonna say well I'd love to play Picasso
Picasso is Picasso but he's got to be
fictionalized and Frank Serpico was
Frank so a real person but in the
theatre and in drama you have to
fictionalize it so you take certain
liberties with bath so it really comes
down to the script being first and
that's why I think so anybody see a good
Picasso script let me know I'm ready to
play him at age 90 kill me so bad he can
taste it
[Applause]
I love the random crazy wild thing it
became out there I love what lament did
to it and and and this kind of person in
this this is lament that is most I mean
it's like a happening and sitting that I
came up to be doing the filming of this
and he said it's out of our hands but he
it's out of our hands and that's the
feeling that I had with it
it was just took it's all on its own
life and he knew it but it also had
versal in it which is what I loved about
Sydney it's very important to me
especially because I just need time I
I'm not the kind of actor that gets it
right away I got up I got a go through
it and I mean three weeks is fine but I
would prefer three months and I think
it's part of coming up out of the
theater theater is proven to me to be a
great teacher yeah you can understand
something if we leave the country
there's no coming back here you know
what I mean there's no coming back so
that if there is anybody now that you
want to talk to you want to say goodbye
to do it now
is there any special country you want to
go to
humming Oh John I love John I first met
John that the we were working for
Standard Oil we were messages I was a
teenager he was little older and I knew
from the moment I met this diaper
everybody liked John I mean you just
would drawn to him because he was such
an interesting person was so open and
you just kind of guy he wanted to know
because there was something in him and
yeah and so I saw him I went up hadn't
seen him in years three or four or five
years and I went up to promise town to
do this thing called the Indian wants
the Bronx Israel harlots room and that
was the first really big thing I have so
I knew this was a role that you know I
was doing children's theater and the
director of the children's dear sent me
this script I thought it he wanted me
for another part but he wanted me for
the part that I eventually played and we
went to Provincetown there's this big
house who all live gonna live in it
little rooms attics I forget the name of
the director his thesis oh yeah we got
the guy who's gonna play the Indian oh I
said you know who and he opens the door
to his room I was living in the big
house it was job I said John you're
playing the Indian this is years so I
got to know him
damn I think that wasn't 65 66 and it
was great it was it was wonderful in the
India once the Bronx was the son of
catalyst my whole life really because
that's how I met Marty Bregman eating
Faye Dunaway came to see it when they
feed them with without know her but she
was huge star and she called Monty
Bregman I didn't I didn't know it David
Begelman head of CIA and they came down
to see to play this little off-broadway
play and that was the role that I always
felt that I had found something
I have arrived there Your Honor that was
it that they kept me body pregnant and
kept me see ma was the and next thing
you know I was doing roles that's the
way it is you know that you can't tell
me that that you know that it's a
combination of sort of application and
luck you know you get lucky if you
sometimes you hang around long enough
you get lucky later in life but I was
lucky that that's what I see it was
lucky I'd met my friend Charlie Lawton
my great mentor it goes right back on
the same Bob luck you know you start
thinking that way as you get older you
start thinking about those pivotal
moments in your life those that
literally save your life especially if
you come from a background I came from I
was from the South Bronx my father and
mother divorced and I remember back then
living with my grandma my grandfather
and my mother but I realized only only
lately how much my grandfather meant to
me as a father substitute as a person he
was such a great person it's so and I
loved him so much and I'd my mother and
my grandmother and that world and my
mother was difficult but she was also
great you know but it doesn't come to
you till later and not in therapy or
anything else he's the owner sudden
something happens and you say oh my yes
because you identify or something
happens in you to say cheese
yeah I was going through life not
realizing it now my father wasn't around
much but to me I think that I'd look at
it some you know some people just have
it a little bit more centered that their
their lives are a little bit more
supportive early on that was walking
down Sunset Boulevard I happened to be
in LA which I was rarely in LA but I was
there I don't know why usually it's
because I was I knew somebody that was
with and I saw the marquee it's it's
Scarface Paul Muni and I thought you
know I heard a lot about that film my
whole life and I knew that a bertolt
brecht loved that the gangster movies of
the 30s the American Gangster looks and
he wrote this great play that I had been
doing a to Louie and growing up had
heard about George Raft and Paul Muni in
Scarface
I went to see it with several friends in
the Tiffany movie house I sawed up there
and this guy Paul Muni was inspiring to
watch I just wanted to imitate that's
the only thing I thought of was
imitating Paul Muni you never know where
you're gonna get inspired you never know
where it's gonna come when it comes from
and you sort of don't even know when
it'll happen but you only hope for it to
happen it's you know sometimes you're
somewhere seeing the play and something
comes to you very much like I guess
anybody who does this stuff whether it's
writing directing whatever painting
something gets you there
but you have a technique you have a
craft and you go through your life doing
that as learning that as as much as you
can but the problem is you you really
relieved and the sense need the craft
when you get inspired
as soon as Lynette got involved and
talked about making it Cuban and all
that and all of a sudden that came in
and the characters started to come to me
through a lot of things Phyllis I
modeled them after a few things one was
Roberto durán I was inspired by Roberto
Duran the fight Earth there was
something about his fire and his is they
that was caught me but it was a
combination of him the actual Paul Muni
and my own
so I don't mean to express something in
it I really felt as though that was
expressing the sense of the underbelly
about our world in a certain way in a
more flamboyant way what the most
difficult guy father was once Francis
wanted me in the film nobody else did
Parham I didn't want me so
that was a very difficult time more for
Francis I remember which is it wasn't I
didn't know what I was getting into and
I knew that I knew Francis from before
he saw me on Broadway in a play and he
he always sort of took an interest in me
and asked me to come to San Francisco
because he had a film and he was living
in San Francisco's otro with Spielberg
and Lucas and all these guys I'd met
when they were young you know so I knew
he was they were doing something
together and it was a real group there
the Warner Brothers didn't want me in
the party and they didn't want the film
or anything so I never heard from them
and a year later I got a call and he
said I'm doing the Godfather which was
the biggest book around the way I'd read
the book and I thought you know is he
awake he was talking from some dream
how's he gonna do the Godfather but I
did think when I heard it I thought you
know Paramount's pretty smart if they
use him if he's telling the truth
that's a good that's a smart move
because I knew how great he was I could
I could tell you that I could feel it
and then he wanted me and they didn't
want me and a serious attest that then
we want him finally got to shoot they
accepted because Jerry Schatzberg my
great friend and direct they gave him
eight minutes from panic and needle Park
I was the Babe Ruth of West 81st
that's right I hit that ball I hit the
ball on the roof one time right I wanted
to get it there was this crap game going
on right I want $79 before my next turn
of bat and when they saw the footage
they hired me and then when I got on
them then they were gonna fire me about
two weeks into it then it didn't care
for what they were seeing Francis said
listen you know I believe in you and all
this but you gotta take a look at the
footage so I went to the Paramount
Building and looked at the footage
because I knew this is it my job is over
now and I watched the footage which I
didn't think was good great or anything
but it wasn't really bad because it was
what I was thinking about in this role
they had given a lot of thought to this
part because she'd had to it's a certain
kind of role and I thought the power of
the role was in the transition from this
kid you don't quite know who he is where
he's going and then before you know it
he becomes this leader and without
without tracking it so I like that that
I would help create a kind of enigmatic
person where does it say that you can't
kill a cop come on Mike Tom wait a
minute I'm talking about a cop that's
mixed up in drugs I'm talking about a
dishonest cop now crooked cop who got
mixed up in the rackets and got what was
coming that's a terrific story
we have newspaper people on a payroll
don't be Tom it might like a story like
that they're mine did just mind it's not
personal Sonny it's strictly business
what was more of a struggle was living
afterward with the aura of that it had
it's that toll in it and then there was
even a strong one with the Godfather - I
thought that was where that care
being that character for you know these
are three our films and those days
eating law year-long shoots so I sort of
have a effect on me my life for a while